la manifestación avanza de manera
tranquila hay varios miles de personas
que marchan aquí en París en total en
Francia son 250 manifestaciones pero las
autoridades ya habían dicho que se
esperaban hoy menos manifestantes que en
las anteriores ocasiones entre
cuatrocientas mil y 700.000 personas la
última expectativa La última carta que
se juega a los sindicatos sindicatos
este día jueves en la asamblea nacional
se va a votar la iniciativa de ley del
grupo que está formado por
independientes y por diputados ultramar
es una iniciativa que busca derogar la
ley tiene posibilidades de ser votadas
sin embargo la presidenta de la asamblea
nacional que es del partido del
presidente Manuel macron ha dicho que
quizás podría no ser recibida esta
iniciativa tiene que ella finalmente
decidir si la recibe o no la comisión de
finanzas de la cámara ya dijo que era un
texto que en todo caso tenía las
condiciones para hacer discutido por lo
tanto con las personas que hemos
conversado aquí nos dicen sigue
manifestando porque quieren demostrar
que no dan su brazo a torcer que están
manifestando por las nuevas generaciones
y contra este gobierno que consideran
poco democrático por la manera en Cómo
se aprobó esta ley recordemos a través
del artículo 49 3 que es básicamente
aprobarlo por decreto sin discusión en
la cámara de diputados Así que los
sindicatos se hace la pregunta sí van a
seguir o no manifestando De esta manera
Por las calles de París y por el resto
de Francia recordemos que también hoy es
una huelga esta está haciendo adherida
de manera más débil en los transportes
solo en lo que son los vuelos
aeronáuticas civil dijo que iba a
interrumpir un tercio de ellos En el
aeropuerto de hoy y en aeropuertos
menores para evitar sobre todo problemas
a los pasajeros donde más estaría
haciendo seguida esta huelga es en la
educación y en los estudiantes de hecho
hoy aquí en París al menos estamos
viendo a muchos jóvenes marchar en
contra de esta reforma y en general en
contra del gobierno de Manuel macron